care what anyone thinks I should be
doing all I want to do is wrestle
when I first started with the monster
Factory I said to myself like if I got
one person to the WWE I'll be happy
Danny cage you have this school at the
monster Factory he teaches you
everything how to do the cameras be a
referee build a ring whenever we're
doing something in here you do it 100
I was working in one of these dead-end
jobs as soon as I walked in I was like
this is awesome
the rush of being in a wrestling ring is
like nothing else
professional wrestling is an Eclectic
Melting Pot of Misfits I mean I'm from
Philly so an underdog is a hungry dog
part of me didn't want to call myself
twitch but how many wrestlers do you
know not only have Tourette's but like
open about it
professional wrestling is a very hard
industry to make it in the odds are
against you I mean there's thousands of
wrestlers every day just trying to get
tryouts but I've gotten more people
there than any other coach in the world
I could either walk out as Champion or I
could go back to flipping burgers we
have 40 students they still have to get
signed and they still have to get better
let's go
my body isn't what it used to be I saw
this goddess crumble you were good right
now you're not
it's just been an off night there's a
lot of stuff happening I tried to quit
and Dan didn't let me I'd have just
constant fear path to Paradise begins in
hell and If You're Going Through Hell
keep going
[Music]
oh God she got invited for a WWE tryout
like
[Music]
[Applause]
wrestle for the WWE hell is the dream
actually they don't kill each other
or if they do just clean up
[Music]